I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today i'm answering
a question from one of our readers named
Luke who has a website called we josh
calm and wanted someone some feedback
and advice on what to do next is that
it's working 15 plus hours a day
developing managing maintaining it I
prenup any help so one of my feedback so
thanks Luke will check it out I know it
can be tough running the business by
yourself and it is a lot of hard work
and effort hopefully we can give you a
little bit of feedback here how to make
this website better so here we are we
dodged calm welcome guests so right away
I don't know what you do and most people
going to bounce so if you look at your
stats you're probably going to see that
most people are not hanging around your
website very long and it bounced right
away so the first thing you want to do
is hit people with what is your golly
proposition what is this website all
about now what do you do if i don't
understand that quickly i'm going to
leave unless somebody said you really
really really have to check out this
website it's awesome but that's probably
not going to happen if they can't
quickly explain what it is that you do
too so you know you have weed osh
filling in the missing pieces no idea
what that means logo doesn't really make
sense you know maybe it means something
but for me checking out the site i don't
really understand what it's all about
the logo is also a little pixelated here
so it wouldn't take much to make that
look nicer a little more professional
even just in Photoshop you use a lot of
real estate at the top everything above
the fold is what somebody's going to
look at quickly when they first sin on
your page use a lot with this huge
graphic that doesn't really mean
anything so I don't know what your logo
means I don't know what all this is all
about
you know the name is there that's great
tagline doesn't make sense I would
shrink this and again offer immediate
value of people who are landing on this
website you may have done a lot of work
here putting this together but you know
half of it is also marketing you got a
position in a way so when people land on
it it makes sense and people want to
kind of take that next step with you
something is little off here where you
have the the tweets likes and Google+
you know they have two thousand Facebook
likes and no tweets this is kind of
raising the BS meter little here maybe
you bought these likes on 50 or
something it doesn't look good to have
all these you know likes and no tweets
it's also kind of skeptical that you
have 18,000 members and 17,000 premium
members I don't know what the difference
is but this seems really high for a
website that doesn't really make too
much sense and has no no tweets attached
to it so for somebody who's coming to
the site it screams warning signs so I
you know you want to be you want to
position yourself to make yourself look
good and put in the best possible light
but people have a pretty good BS
detector as well and if you're you know
massively inflating your numbers people
will tell and they're not going to want
to do business with you so I you know
obviously want to put yourself in the
best light possible but I wouldn't be
inflating those numbers if you want
people to sign up and take you seriously
let's see we have below so members earn
and benefit your earnings in many ways
affiliates multiply and maximize your
earnings advertises boost sales and
increase website traffic okay
you know still not a hundred percent
what this is all about latest job
opportunities work from no home it's a
whole bunch of different affiliate
programs you're trying to get me a sign
up for this affiliate program so this
will that I'm gonna be promoting a lot
of people run away soon as I see a lot
of affiliate offers so again you may
have done a lot of work programming this
but it doesn't make sense for somebody
to visiting the site like the good news
is if you can modify it to change your
message and clearly explain what it is
that you do if there is real value there
then you know we easier to get people to
sign up and take whatever next step you
want them to take you've got a bunch of
social media links oles see what you
have in google+ so that just loads a
picture i click on it okay so you don't
actually have these accounts it's just
loading pictures okay so you know again
that's not going to look good if I want
to follow you on facebook or google+ or
youtube and is these are just links to
pictures but doesn't actually show your
accounts again it doesn't look good so
it you know it just damages a
credibility if I come to this page and
I've been referred or got a linked
somehow and I see that you have links to
social media accounts that don't work
and you've got you know all these
members which looks a little sketchy and
you know no tweets in two thousand likes
again it looks very sketchy to
understand what this website does people
are gonna leave right away so if you can
fix that up again you know right here in
the home page you clearly explain what
it is that you do take away this you
know all this affiliate stuff here which
I'm not sure if you're trying to sell me
or what the whole point of these are but
if you clean up your marketing message
make it make sense take away the stuff
that would alert people negatively like
like this 0 tweet and 2,000 likes and
make your social media accounts here you
know either work or just take them off I
probably also get rid of this
advertising especially on your homepage
well it doesn't look that great if you
can clean all that up and explain your
offer I think you'll have a much greater
chance of getting people to take
whatever next step you're doing you know
you work in 15 hours a day plus you know
welcome to the club that's that's part
of entrepreneurship for for most people
who are starting up you want to make
sure you're spending that time wisely
and maybe you spent most of it on the
programming and the backend stuff but
now it's time to figure out the
marketing and the positioning and the
messaging so that people quickly
understand the value that you can bring
and want to sign up with you and go to
the next step so hopefully that helped
for those of you guys watching if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below and it also love to hear oh you
have to think about this website or if
you have a question about your own
business I'd love to hopefully answer it
for you in one of these future videos so
thank you and we'll see you on the next
episode
you